ما نشاهده حسن الان عبر الشاشه هو حقيقه
حقيقه مكتب الجزيره في مدينه غزه الذي كان
يعتلي سطحه الزميل وائل الدحدوح والزملاء
الاعزاء في مكتبنا هناك بعد ان اضطروا الى
مغادرته في الاسابيع الماضيه نستطيع ان
نكشف رغم انه قريب من المنطقه الجنوبيه
الغربيه اينه قريب الى البحر وكما اشرت في
مره سابقه اننا نستطيع ان هذا المبنى مبنى
مكتبنا
في قطاع غزه بسبب كل الدمار الذي تراه في
ال نعم هو المبنى الذي تراه الان في وسط
الشاشه
اي وهذا مبنى الجزيره مبنى مكتبنا ونستطيع
ان نراه بفعل كل هذا الدمار الذي كنت
اتحدث عنه حسن في المنطقه الشرقيه لمدينه
غزه تخيل حجم الدمار الكبير اننا نقف على
بعد ربما كيلومترين تقريبا او ربما اقل من
ذلك من السياج الامني لكننا نستطيع ان
نكشف الجهه تقريبا القريبه من البحر في
قطاع غزه على بعد ربما اكثر من 10
كيلومترات من من الموقع الذي نراه وهذا
سببه الدمار الشديد الذي خلفته الاله
العسكريه الاسرائيليه في المناطق الشرقيه
بطبيعه الحال
مباني للتوضيح هنا يعني قبل هذه الحرب هذا
المبنى الذي يظهر يبدو انه مبنى
زجاجي هذا المبنى لم يكن يظهر قبل الحرب
لكن بعد الحرب نتيجه الدمار
و احاله كل المباني العاليه الى حطام بات
هذا يظهر بكل وضوح
امامكم بالفعل من المنطقه التي نقف فيها
في غلاف غزه في الناحيه الشرقيه لمدينه
غزه قباله حي الشجاعيه على وجه التحديد
هذا هو مكتبنا ولم نكن نراه حقيقه من قبل
لم يكن بالامكان رؤيته لانه هو اصلا هو
موجود في عمق قطاع غزه في عمق المدينه لكن
بعد هذا الدمار الكبير الذي احالته الاله
العسكريه الاسرائيليه من دمار في كل هذه
المناطق الشرقيه وتدمير المباني الشاهقه
العاليه التي كانت تحيط به وكذلك تلك
القريبه منا القريبه من السياج الامني
تحديدا اصبح بالامكان رؤيه مكتبنا الان
بالعين المجرده حتى من منطقه غلاف غزه
طبعا امنياتنا طبقى دائما حسن بعوده
الزملاء الاعزاء الى هذا المكتب لاعمار
ولموا التغطيه للمواصله كشف الحقيقه ايه
واضح بان الدمار هنا كبير للغايه ايه حسن
واه هذه ربما اشاره الى ما تقوم به القوات
الاسرائيليه منذ اسابيع في اطار عمليتها
العسكريه التي تهدف كما اشرت الى انشاء
هذه ال المنطقه ال العازله لا يعرف بعد
حسن حجم هذه المنطقه او الى اي عمق تريد
اسرائيل الدخول فيها او اقامه هذه المنطقه
هل هي لكيلو متر او الى كيلومترين لا احد
يدري لكن واضح بان السياسه تتجه في هذا
السياق